[Music]
voodoomanuel c 6
mr textmate 2 To the champion
[Music]
Yes, my name is Kentaro Sakai
My occupation is in Hiroshima prefecture, where Nishiki-koi is produced and sold
.  The first way I learned
how to grow this kind of ancestor from Dairei is from
my father
. It's like I've taken over this job naturally now
.
There are about 70
kinds of Nishiki-koi that I'm doing like that.
Red and white Well, Akatsu white love and Taisho Sanshoku red and black and white
These are the only two varieties.
I live, but the peak of beauty is still 10
years old. After
all
, my love is wonderful. First of all, the system
is wonderful
and glossy.
Bd 6 d project
looking for sql
Sporty Junpei
normad Sabers 2 Figure
Wedge Noodles Up Bar Stool &
Perfect  re
Speaking of the important element of Koi no Shiku, after all water
How to make good water
and how to make delicious food and
give it to the act is the most important element
[Music]
Nishiki-koi has a very good taste.  It's well developed and I understand that
this food is delicious and bad
.
rbk With ball Audi a
Polinfish Henry Bragg
mdb 2
do
do Star
body The wonderfulness of that body shape and the
gloss of the color texture.
It's becoming very important
to win the championship for the first time in 2000 and to win the championship
10 times until 2020 this year
rds for a happy d e
re not to do
noo
me some bnx Pants Par b
Koide, who won the championship, is called Legend.
This love
set a new world record at that auction, and it's a
love with a balance of
203 million.
If you receive a happy voice from us, it's
also a sense of accomplishment, which leads to a sense of satisfaction.  After
all, for me, the ceremony is
like my child, so I'm really happy to see
the children growing up and becoming beautiful
.
[Music]
adele b
er 4  n d
render
Mole Spiser Recha Ah Parker Esperfa web
Gay Bar Casdau rebig
story